it started as a legend one of the
greatest of all thousand years who've.
kept it hidden to protect Earth from.
what was destined to arrive Optimus.
Prime you destroyed your home he's secret
Prudential money maker I do
your daughter what would you say to her
Oh shooty orcard stay with money boy  event especially a
drummer
these are trouble times without leaders
chaos reigns
two worlds colliding
you're all that stand in its way now the
greatest mission of them all to turn the
tide of human history
I can't do this
the illness destruction of everything we
know and love begins
I'm not leaving you
my no seems lost a few brave souls
can save everything you've ever known the
operations over when I keep it up a
prime okay
I'm staying
and want to fight them
or my will to live
yours must die